>> Ken: I THINK JACK HUGHES
POKES
HIS BACK.
PATRICK MAROON HITS TY SMITH AN
AND THEN LIGHTNING.
ONDREJ PALAT AND NIKITA KUCHEROV
ON THE PUCK, SAVE BY GILLIES.
VASILEVSKIY TO STEER IT AWAWGOVH
A POWER-PLAY GOAL.
>> Ken: A RARE LOOK AT THIS.
QUQU
BACKHANDS THAT OFF THE WALL.
JACK HUGHES ZONE AS HE
GOT THAT PUCK OFF THE WALL TOY
HISCHIER ON
HE SCORED.
STEVEN STAMKOS AND THE LIGHTNING
ICKS
THAT PUCK OFF HIS BACKHAND
QUICKLY TO HIS  QUICK
STRIDES.
ONE MORE BUT S NOW HEDMAN TO CO
PUCK AGAIN.
CONTROLS THE GAME WIT PUCK.
THE EX-ANAHEIM DUCK -- AND A
DRIVE BY HEDMAN GOT THROUGH.
HE SCORED.
IN TRANSITION
WRIST SHOT PAST GILLIES.
SCORE!
IT WAS BELLEMARE CLEANING U U
BELLEMARE JUST ONE-HANDER POKES
AT THE PBAY HAS DONE
HERE.
>> Steve: THE PASS COMES OUT TO